the city of Chicago is suing Empire
actor Jesse Smollett after he refused to
reimburse police for the cost of an
investigation into an alleged hate crime
police say he staged Chicago is seeking
more than three times the amount of
damages previously requested Dean
Reynold is in Chicago with how the
potential cost for Smollett could go
even higher dean good morning good
morning this civil lawsuit was filed
just 16 days after the state's attorney
here dropped all criminal charges
against the actor despite initially
saying that the case against them was
quite strong that decision outraged the
mayor and the police and it left a lot
of people here wondering why according
to the lawsuit filed by the city late
Thursday more than two dozen police
officers and detectives were involved in
the two-week investigation they racked
up more than a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars of overtime pay city
code allows Chicago to collect up to
three times the amount of damages
sustained which could be as much as
three hundred and ninety thousand
dollars evidence sealed in the criminal
case could be unsealed if this civil
case goes to trial
Smollett might have to testify as a
witness where he presumably would have
to talk about the evidence the police
say proves he lied now Smollett has said
he is innocent and his attorneys say
it's the city of Chicago that owes him
an apology but if the city wins this
lawsuit and Smollett continues to refuse
to pay up his bank accounts could be
frozen Gail yeah a story not over yet
thank you very much